my husband likes to drink um like
Friday sometimes Friday through Sunday
wow and then during that time he like he
forgets about our like a budget yeah
you're married to somebody who's really
struggling with
alcohol this has this is not a budgeting
issue at
all yeah this is that you love um
someone who's an
alcoholic yeah and it sucks CU he does
see it that way so it seems like I'm the
nagging wife right and here's uh what
you've got to
do um unfortunately there is no healing
in your marriage there's no healing in
your financial life there's no healing
in underneath your marriage and
underneath your financial all that all
that leads to this moment where you
don't feel safe in your own house do
you no no none of that changes until he
chooses to get clean